do you know there is another way in
which we can write square roots this can
be written as 5 raised to 1 by 2 how can
we write the cube root of 7 it can be
written as 7 raised to 1 by 3 if we have
something like the nth root of a it can
be written as a raise to 1 by n this is
a very important concept you need to
understand in order to solve fractional
exponents problems the nth root of a is
equal to a raise to 1 by n but just this
concept isn't enough a raise to M the
whole raise to n is equal to a raise to
M times n this is called the Prolog
understand it well a raise to M the
whole raise to n is equal to a raise to
M times n these two are multiplied in
the power so if we have something like 5
raise to 2 the whole raise to 3 it can
be written as 5 raise to 2 times 3 and
that equals 5 raise to 6 now what kind
of problems can be asked in the exams
may be something like a trace to 2 by 3
8 is the base and 2 by 3 is the
fractional exponent how do we simplify
this it's interesting we can write it as
8 raised to 2 times 1 by 3 it's the same
2 by 3 is the same as 2 times 1 by 3 and
based on the power law we saw this can
be written as 8 squared raised to 1 by 3
this was in the air raised to M times n
form and this is in the air raise to M
the whole raise to n form as 8 squared
is 64 this will equal 64 raised to 1 by
3 and guess what this is this is in the
a raise to 1 by n form this is the cube
root of 64 and that is for this
weird-lookin number was
reduce to an integer using two basic
concepts we learned here's another one
the square root of 64 the whole raised
to 1 by 3 try it out
what is route 64 it's 8 so this will be
a trace to 1 by 3 and this is the cube
root of 8 which is 2 the 2 concepts we
learnt are more than enough to solve
problems based on fractional exponents